bonsoir les skis vous êtes donc à
barcelone où se tenait l'un des
rassemblements les plus importants ce
soir et ils étaient des centaines pour
le premier mois d'incarcération du
rappeur catalan arrêté le 7 février
dernier c'était symbolique pour eux de
se retrouver aujourd'hui la plateforme
du soutien pablo à celle avait tenu à
convoquer plusieurs rassemblements en
même temps dans différentes villes de
catalogne alors on le rappelle pas beau
à celle a été condamné une première fois
pour apologie du terrorisme et injures à
l'encontre de la couronne
ça concerne en tout 64 tweets publiés
entre 2014 et 2016 est une chanson
contre l'ancien roi d'espagne juan
carlos puis là sa peine a été alourdie
juste après son arrestation il a été
condamné pour avoir menacé le témoin
témoin pendant un procès en 2017
et puis la semaine dernière l'audience
nationale a ajouté 16 mois de prison
supplémentaires pour ne pas avoir payé
trois amendes
le rappeur catalan avait déclaré depuis
le début qu'il ne les paierai pas et
depuis je riais ce que la mobilisation a
faibli et désherber les manifestations
se font moins régulière alors il faut
rappeler que suite à l'arrestation
mouvementée du rappeur catalans
s'étaient retranchés dans une université
de catalogne des rassemblements s'était
tenue le jour même mais aussi les
semaines suivantes
à barcelone les dégâts dans l'espace
public avait dépassé le million d'euros
au total
enquête elle n 142 personnes ont été
arrêtées alors plus que de demander la
liberté de pablo à sel et de prôner la
liberté d'expression c'est devenu un
conglomérat de luttes sociales
car après un an de pandémie et de
restrictions l'arrestation de pablo à
celle a été l'étincelle qui a enflammé
les jeunes militants barcelonais c'est
une façon pour eux de montrer leur
hostilité face au gouvernement espagnol
mais aussi de pointer du doigt la
précarité car en espagne le chômage bat
des records
le droit au logement et les retraites
font également partie des revendications
et même si ces revendications sont
nombreuses la mobilisation est en baisse
le soutien politique a également faibli
en main en février les réactions étaient
nombreuses mais ce mois de mars elles se
sont faites plus rares
merci beaucoup disent la cible et smith
england directeur de barcelone